cent mille c'est le nombre d'emplois
saisonniers non pourvus dans la
restauration chaque année depuis dix ans
une données avancées par la profession
certains pensent que c'est même
davantage en cause la crise sanitaire
qui a d'abord empêché puis démotivés
nombre de personnel de travailler
conséquence directe dans ce bistrot de
l'oise où les candidats se font plutôt
rares
on cherche depuis depuis et 5,5 mois
devrait en est un c'est très compliqué
parce qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup il n'y a
pas beaucoup de candidats
et puis on est sûr beaucoup plus
d'offres que de demandes
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'offre et la
demande est aujourd'hui un candidat
quand ils cherchent du travail dans ce
métier là il a il a que l'embarras du
choix
savoir comment il va trouver où il va
travailler quelques avantages il va
avoir par rapport à une autre entreprise
quel type de de cuisine il va faire ou
de service fait l'autre conséquence de
la crise sanitaire le besoin de vivre
différemment car travailler dans
l'hôtellerie restauration ressemble
parfois un sacerdoce
alors les syndicats de la profession
avec les entreprises ont décidé
d'assouplir les conditions de travail et
rendre le secteur beaucoup plus
attractif beaucoup aussi d'entreprises
essaie de se réinventer de se
réorganiser nous on a pas mal
d'adhérents par exemple qu'on réduit les
services qui travaillent moins deux
soirs par semaine 2 3 4 au lieu de cinq
ou six pour pour permettre d'avoir une
vie de famille on a aussi maintenant
beaucoup de restaurants comptent deux
jours de congés payés ce qui n'était pas
le cas avant on pouvait avoir un jour et
de nuit journée c'est quand même pas la
même chose donc voilà tout le monde a
fait des efforts sur les conditions de
travail les conditions de vie on a aussi
beaucoup travaillé l'ergonomie
on a aujourd'hui du matériel qui est
autonettoyant comporte plus de charges
dont qu'on a on a des métiers qui sont
vraiment beaucoup plus porté sur sur le
conseil sur les changes sur l'expérience
client que sur du travail pénibles ou
difficiles et pour remédier à ce
problème l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie lance une
plateforme en ligne est une application
mobile dédiée au recrutement avec la
réouverture progressive des bars et des
terrasses est était le secteur aura au
moins deux
de 300000 saisonniers